ちょっと今日は
本当に
すごいことを知ると思うこれはね友達に教えてもらったんですけど
まずですごい実験です
検索してもなかなかヒットしないやすくていい
まあコーラにそれ
講義つれ作っていったのだ
ああああああああ
こういうのね
コーナーに入れると
こらー
透明になるんです
まさか俺も聞いたときわー
とても剤がなぁ
信じれなかった
まとりあえずやってみましょう
透明なコーラってまた不思議ですよねじゃ行くぜ
me
パスワード付
まず
とかグループうのっ
見えるバウム
me
なんか浮く反応みたいもん
んをっ
このおっ
bar わーってなってわかりますようーん
なんかこう
多分触れコーヒーフレッシュが何かあっ
コーラを取っ取ろうとするんですねば
まあなんか着燃えてるん
うわぁ
地下が凄いかっ
まあポップアップするぞ
pro なんでー
混ぜたるなる
ホオのんっ
もっといればいい
あーぽいなぁ
もっと入れたほうがいいよこれ
4日
向き建ちたキター
1著書ぞ
このすごい
メールなんかすぐブツブツブツブツってなったらふぉ
ほれ
ほ
やばいって前8位これはこれはすごいやばい
期待スクープ大スクープ
すげー
うわぁ
やばい
ん
んん
2まぁこんな感じ
コーラと思えないですね
ああこらねー
エッグは分
すごいなんか時間だったらこんな通りになるんですよ
これコーナーですよ
と見えるそろっ
コカコーラねー
コーラの味する
こーなーにー
コーヒーのミルクですねコーヒーグレ所
ある程度入れると環化反応がおっ
コーランの色素が抜けます
を踊った